for Philippine Coast Guard Personnel
this has become a daily routine heading
out to sea to contain the spread of
industrial fuel it's been leaking from a
tanker that capsized on February the
28th
we're spraying basically the oil Shins
so that it will be disturbed and the
environment will take its effect
the empty princess Empress was carrying
more than 900 000 liters of unrefined
fuel when it went down
private contractors are working in
tandem with the Coast Guard deploying
booms temporary floating barriers and
collecting oil with skimmers
see that shiny stretch over there it's
about a kilometer and a half that's the
oil that's spilling out from the tanker
at the moment now at the end of that
stretch was where the sunken tanker was
found about 400 meters down at the
bottom of the sea
authorities say The Spill is largely
under control and that a siphoning ship
has been hired to finish the job
it will suck all all the possible or
remaining oil on board
until then however Coastal communities
are worried about a bigger disaster
these are just from leaks we may not
have seen the worst of the oil spill we
don't know when the ships contain our
bulbs might blow wide open
the local government of Paula the town
where most of the oil had washed ashore
says coral reefs have been damaged it
intends to take legal action
once the oil reaches the corals it will
take years 10 20 years for the corals to
be clean again and the corals and also
the mangroves are the breeding areas of
the fish so how can the fish breathe in
that area in our Province if the corals
if they're building areas are silted
with oil
for now fishermen are getting by
earning money in exchange for removing
oil from the beaches
but they don't want to just get by they
say they want to thrive and they don't
know any other way of life but fishing
barn and Below Al Jazeera Oriental
mindoro the Philippines